all right so i'm really excited we're
live on youtube if you were here for the
candy pre-show you're welcome that was
unexpected treat for everybody in this
spooky season but good morning good
afternoon and i am so excited to have
you all here with us today as we kick
off our hiring great data science teams
panel my name is jessie mosspack and
while i am currently a developer
advocate with the shiny team here at
rstudio
not that long ago i was a data science
job seeker who eventually got their
first data science job before moving
into data science management so i know
that we have a lot of ground to cover
today with our panelists and i cannot
wait for them to have the opportunity to
share their advice and experiences with
you so we have four fantastic panelists
uh today we'll be hearing from rhonda
crait principal data scientist at boeing
an adjunct professor at washington state
university we have katie schaefer who is
the manager of advanced analytics at
beam dental also jairus thing director
of quantitative analytics at pandora and
yui sang vp of analytics at amwell so
really an incredible incredible
panel with a ton of advice and
experience and please feel free to put
your questions in chat uh we do have a
list of prepared questions but as always
we would love to hear from you as well
so to kick things off all of you come
from data science backgrounds and i'm
really curious how that experience has
helped inform your ability to manage a
data science team so i'll throw that
over to eway first
[Music]
uh sure so um
i my background is in statistics that's
what i went to graduate school for um
and that was a really natural transition
so one of my first jobs out of grad
school
the title is senior analyst but i was
working with health care data
and responsibilities and tasks you know
involved
r sql working with large databases
doing analyses basically all of the
range of skills you would expect the
data scientists
to have today so
the you know that experience of course
was helpful to understand the technical
side but i think
just like any other job whether it's
data scientists or you know i don't know
marketing associate anything
uh the biggest and most important part
in terms of uh getting to where i was
it's learning
uh how a business functions and just the
day-to-day operations you know
understanding the importance of
emotional intelligence working with
other people
being organized paying attention to
process so those are i think more
important than the actual data science
technical jobs themselves
uh so it's just really being open and
curious as much as all data scientists
are to
uh those other aspects of the job
rhonda how about you i'd love to hear
how you know coming from a data
background has influenced your your
management style
sure um my management style or the first
question sorry um so i'm not technically
a manager um i'm an associate technical
fellow which is a slightly different
role in management we really take on the
technical responsibilities of the team
in guiding technical vision for
execution um but i'll just kind of add
to um my background is uh in statistics
and i have a needy cat right now so um i
might just hold her here because
otherwise she'll just keep jumping up
here
um and um my i have an undergraduate and
a graduate degree in anthropology
actually which is really different than
most people in this field
and um what it especially like my
anthropology degree what what happens is
um it just makes me realize the
importance of diversity on the team
because people with different
backgrounds and different skills whether
you're from statistics yes economics or
you know environmental science everybody
brings a unique perspective to solving
real problems right and how we do with
that with data and so
really that's that's kind of what i look
for um in a team is you know do we have
different set of skills how can we bring
those skills and methodologies to solve
problems that we have
jairus how about you can you tell us a
bit about your background and how that
helps inform managing a data science
team
yeah definitely
um so i came up through you know the
team that i now manage so i started as
an analyst on that team and and sort of
worked my way up to to be in charge of
it now and i think the biggest thing is
that when you've done the work yourself
it gives you a very i think good idea of
how to
ask people to do that work and i try to
be sort of like the boss like it i think
it's easy for me to ask myself like what
was my ideal boss when i was an analyst
and then how do i try to become that and
i think it works well when you've done
the work because
that vision tends to be more aligned
with something that's achievable and
good for the business but when you're
managing people and you don't share
those experiences it's a lot harder to
one formulate what that good boss looks
like and then also to become it and in
some cases it may be almost unreasonable
right if you're in charge of a bunch of
different groups of teams with sort of
competing priorities you may need to
make decisions that benefit one over the
other but having done the work and then
having been in charge of the small team
i think i have a very good idea of what
it entails and also how to make sure
that it's communicated well and it
maximizes impact so sort of being being
the person i wanted to have when i was
doing it is how i go about it i think
it's worked pretty well so far
but that's sort of my strategy yeah
cool and then i guess
yeah from my perspective i would kind of
echo everything everyone um just said
i'd say um some ads there would be
coming from a phd program or academia i
think i'm more sensitive on the hiring
front to the skill set that they bring
even though oftentimes they will lack
you know an actual job experience
outside of academia
just thinking through their experience
as
job experience is really important and i
think they can be valuable skill sets to
the team but then also knowing kind of
the skill gaps that they'll come with
right since they have not worked in
more of an industry setting
um and then i think one thing i didn't
appreciate in my old job that i do
appreciate in my new job so my old job i
was a data scientist there was no really
analytics team it was more of a
consulting firm my new job i started out
managing the analytics team so i think
finally i've gotten kind of a full
circle lens of how those two teams can
really complement one another data
science and analytics the differences
and kind of the complementary nature
between the two
um yeah so i'd say that definitely
informs my hiring of data scientists
knowing hey where do we want to take and
pick up some of the work that the
analysts have done and how will those
two teams and two
folks work together so
yeah that's really great you've kind of
queued us up for this next question so
i'm going to start with you katie but
i'd really love to hear i know that
everyone watching has questions about
this and i know we all have experience
with this but starting with katie how do
you feel
or what do you feel are the best ways to
assess a candidate's technical ability
yeah so
a lot of different options for this of
course
i think my goal as a hiring manager is
just
again to your first question right
having done the work yourself to at
least some degree
i think allows you to just assess in
some of their answers do they know what
they're talking about or is there kind
of a level of are they reaching a little
bit too far on some of the skills
so i think that my technical experience
helps with that but i think one thing we
do here at beam is we have a take-home
test
a simulated data i think the
it is really important to assess those
technical skills in an interview but i
think the one thing that i'm really not
a fan of is kind of
to a point i think certain more
traditional like white boarding
or brain teaser questions and interviews
i think at a certain point they kind of
just measure performance under duress
versus performance
so i think there's a happy medium
between whether you're doing kind of a
live technical interview live coding
making that productive and um
worth the time in terms of assessing the
skills you want to assess
take home is certainly another route
that i've become a fan of but i've seen
the kind of more live technical
interviews done well and then so maybe
not so well
where you know folks might have missed
out on some good candidates just because
they asked a brain teaser that the
person didn't get in those five minutes
um so that's kind of my quick take
um i'll kind of follow up um i so i'm
i'm a huge fan of them
basically talking about what they're
passionate about and describing
situations where they've actually
applied it and some of the um key
criteria you know that we probably look
for and some of those answers are like
you know is somebody coming up to you
and asking you for advice on how to
solve these problems right
um are you being a mentor to somebody
else because that's usually you know a
way that you can share your skills with
somebody else that means you're
confident enough to to demonstrate your
skills and then share that with somebody
else and and basically teach right
um also your
you know your your ability to describe
it in a technical manner in a situation
which you applied it because honestly
like you know people come from a variety
of different backgrounds there's a whole
bunch of different language that
different backgrounds use to describe
the same processes
and so um you know i really like the
approach of asking them to describe a
situation that they've been in what was
the outcome of that and really describe
the result in a technical format in
you can usually tell when somebody's
passionate about something and let them
kind of pursue their their passions a
little bit
um but at the same time making sure that
the skills that we need for the job
right
i agree uh technical exercise is really
important uh
i've always used them it's you know it's
it's uh it's really the only way you can
quickly and accurately assess the
technical skills
um so i think it's it's required um
also just you know the basic uh
interviewing and job seeking 101
expectations you know uh well put
together resume of course you know no
typos things like that things they
teach you over and over again
um
and then uh over time at least i i like
to think i've developed like a intuition
also you know it's it's well it's more
of the intuition it's you know it's on
the resume it's also in in the actual
interview process themselves you can
start to assess
to the extent you know that person is
really uh curious and passionate about
the work itself
so curiosities
curiosity and energy to me are my number
number one and two uh traits that i look
for
you know if if you've only learned uh
how to write r on the j you know
for a couple years or
in grad school
i think you can pick those things up but
you can't you can't teach someone to be
really curious and really energetic you
know
um yeah and then finally
uh when we do start having technical
discussions i i think this is reflected
in what ronda said you know it's a
matter of
uh does this person know what they're
talking about and so i listened for are
they being specific in what they're
describing
if they start speaking in generalities
and you know
vague answers you know pretty quickly
they don't really
they aren't really well suited for this
kind of job
for sure yeah i'm an echo a lot of
things that were said i'm on team take
home as well and i hate doing brain
teasers in interviews or even asking
people to do them it's i don't know it
feels like torture a lot of the time um
but a plea for hiring managers out there
you know try to make sure that you're
asking sort of as little of folks that
you can to get a good assessment on them
to just be respectful of their time
because what happens is and it i think
it works in your favor because you have
some very brave folks out there who are
like hey you know i don't know if i need
to invest four hours into this when i
have two offers so you're going to turn
away folks who you know really do know
what they're doing if you make it to
sort of heavy um and and the opposite
logic which i don't agree with as well
if they really cared they would sink in
all this time and energy and i just
don't agree with that um but for us you
know i think there's a big concern that
well what if they get a lot of help on
the take home you're not really
assessing their ability so we like to
ask a lot of follow-up questions during
the interviews and we'll usually use one
of our interviews to say okay you made
this decision here you made this choice
you're using this technique can you tell
me a little more about it and then we're
doing what you have said of you know is
this something that your friend told you
to do and you have no idea how the
technique works and you can't answer
questions or is it something that you
have knowledge of so that's how we sort
of try to bring that all together in our
interview process
yeah that's really interesting a lot of
great great perspectives here and we've
had a question from the audience that
really dovetails nicely with this so i'd
be really curious if you change the way
that you assess a candidate based on
their kind of educational background so
for example you know data science
degrees are now a thing that people can
get um but if someone comes from a
quantitative background computer science
statistics data science versus someone
coming from um you know just a
non-quantitative background education or
you know policy or literature do you
change how you assess that individual in
an interview
or or no maybe everybody's a no but i'd
be really curious if there's anything
how you kind of may approach that
differently if at all
i'd say that the first thing that sticks
out to me is a little bit less of what i
do kind of where the conversation heads
but to me it's really important you
whatever your applicant management
system is it's really important that
you're keeping up with the recruiting
like the lead recruiter on it to make
sure that person gets an interview
um that's what i found to be the most
crucial way in which i step in which i
typically wouldn't is just giving the
head recruiter that like commenting when
we see the application and staying
stupid on top of it myself um because
it's a little bit harder sometimes for
them to spot like oh well this person
with this non-traditional background has
the skills you want or not
um so i just make sure that i get a
chance to talk to that person if i see
that they've got some components that
are maybe non-traditional but speak to
their skill set
yeah and i'll kind of add that as
somebody who comes from a more
non-traditional stat background right i
graduated with a liberal arts degree and
and then i got my stat degree but
um i i will say like personally as as i
entered job interviewing i was worried
that my anthropology degree would
actually set me back
but the reality i mean still had a stat
like i still have a master's in stats
but um
the reality is it brought an element
that differentiated me from the
candidates and um i will say at boeing
everybody gets the same
opportunity of interview for that up so
everybody gets the same question so as
as far as that goes that that's a
standardized process that our hr has
developed right um but i i would
encourage like any people that just have
a solid like science background to go
out and discover the liberal arts
because it it can only make you better
right
that's my personal view
i love that right so if you're coming
from a quantitative background go out
discover you know do things outside of
of your your educational background so
this really ties into a question and i'd
love to start with you jairus um skills
like empathy and communication are often
mentioned as like absolute must-haves
for data scientists but how do you know
a candidate has these skills
yeah um i went through this great
training at work a while ago and it was
sort of a generalist training it was not
for hiring technical roles it was just
hiring in general
and they went over a really good
framework for asking behavioral
questions and what i thought was so
unusual about it was that like the
questions to me seem to have obvious
answers but if you ask 10 people or 10
data scientists you're going to get rid
of three of them because they're not
going to give you the answer that that
you would want and so what we do is we
sort of ask these we put them in
situations that are sort of undesirable
and i i don't mean literally in the
interview i mean we ask them about
situations that are undesirable you know
you've gotten a vague request from a
stakeholder and we see how they deal
with those situations and
i think folks who who deal well with
that you know first say okay you know i
get that this happens on the job and i
will work with them to come to an answer
but there's always a subset of folks who
who um kind of put it back on you and is
like wasn't your job to prevent these
things from happening or like why would
i be in this position and it's you know
as much as i'd love to live in a world
in which it never happens it always
happens and so it's kind of an easy way
i've found to ask those behavioral
questions about you know difficult
situations that involve working with
people or communicating things to people
and seeing sort of how flexible data
scientists applicants can be
in their answers so it was funny to me
because when i first learned these i'm
like well no one's going to say like i
shouldn't do that or that's my job but
you end up picking up a few people who
genuinely do feel that way and and you
know i'm sure they're a great fit for
another role out there but but that role
isn't one of ours
yeah for sure it's and you know it's
kind of nice to to get to that point um
where you know right like you you don't
want to pull a candidate along um if
they're if they're not a good fit so as
we're talking about hiring i'd love to
hear from you to to kick things off in
terms of how do you know when it's time
to grow your data science team and kind
of to piggyback off of that what
strategies do you employ
when you're growing your team
um
everywhere i've been
it's always well i've always been hired
because i needed to grow the team so
they hired me to grow the team
uh so it's it's all the answer is always
pretty much most you know most for most
firms that are data rich obviously could
stand to use
uh more data scientists but
um
you know
to answer your question directly
it's really a matter of demand right
last i've been doing this for a long
time and and we just never have enough
data scientists
the type of teams that i've managed have
always been uh internal support and
external support supporting clients and
supporting other functions like
marketing
uh sales operations etc so the the
appetite for data is you know uh
bottomless
so we're always in growth mode
and then when it when it comes to
actually um
building out the team which i'm
currently in the situation
you know i really want to
try to build out a team that's diverse
uh in all aspects you know uh
technically
uh and experience wise
you know there is no such thing as a
data scientist who can do everything
i also don't want to tame a data
scientist where everyone has the exact
same set of skills so you're gonna have
people who are
uh more experienced with you know on the
data engineering side people who are
more experienced on the statistical
modeling side etc in terms of experience
uh you know having people from different
backgrounds uh
in terms of degrees that's a great thing
because they bring different skill sets
and people from different industries you
know
uh
because uh that allows
you know uh
everyone brings their best practices and
we can learn and teach from each other
learn and grow from each other you know
that's that's how i've i've done that
that's how i've done it and it's worked
well so far
yeah i really love that statement that
everybody brings their best practices i
think that um
that's just such a wonderful way to
think about about growing a team
so i would also really love to hear from
folks uh we have a question from the
audience around managers staying in the
code uh so in other words what are your
thoughts and feelings about management
and being a manager and should a manager
still be able to write and review code
as well as solve technical questions
if you're at a startup yes
uh
yeah i i've
i've flamed out a few times at a few
startups and you know not surprisingly
you're you're short stuff there so
you're expected to pitch in
uh but in my experience this is just my
experience only in healthcare um
you know once you go beyond the director
level uh i think it's important for the
manager to actually be the um you know
the one well managing because
uh again this goes back to my firm
belief that process is really important
you know you can't just have people just
running around doing whatever they want
to do
you have to steer the ship everyone in
the right direction it's a lot of work
you know
um
get
i can still read r you know a little bit
but you know i i won't be nearly as
efficient as as the people who are
actually much better at it so
you don't want me writing the code
yeah you know instead you want me going
out there
you want your manager going out there
and
and
think of it this way finding more
business for the team because finding
more business for the team whether it's
internal or external means more
opportunities for you
to do other things you know
work on other subject areas uh add
additional technical skills
uh so that's that's how i think that's
how i view myself
i'll kind of add because i'm not a
manager right um but that's one of the
great and awesome things about boeing is
we kind of have different career paths
so you can go into management or you can
be just a really awesome employee or you
can go into the technical fellowship
which is a career path driven towards
technical excellence and like like i'm
an r boeing designated expert right
there's not very many of those at the
boeing company and and so that's awesome
like i can help you program and
management can really focus on those
more hr and going out and getting the
business thing um while at the same time
technical fellows also can kind of
participate in that going out and
getting the business and where the
technical vision and and things like
that are and so i i think i i like
boeing for that because if you really
want to focus on technical excellence
you can really drive your career
in that direction you don't necessarily
have to end up in in management
that's all
yeah that's great with that being said
though managers should still be data
literate
i love it i love the enthusiasm katie
and jairus anything to to add on that
i'm seeing a lot of nodding so i'm not
sure if we're all like yeah this i agree
with this or maybe someone is like no
absolutely managers should be coding
every day
i think um it really just like others
have said depends on the stage of the
company so i think at a certain point it
while it sounds nice i think it'd be fun
it it can be unrealistic to expect that
somebody who's managing multiple
different teams or folks has the time to
to program considerably every day but i
do think you need to have a level of
competency and
ideally you have had experience in the
role or can do the role in your history
because i think if you don't have enough
experience
it can be hard to spot the root cause of
some like personnel issues or maybe
other friction you're experiencing
because if you can't go in and assess
the issues with the code or the
performance
it'll be hard for you as a manager to do
that but at a certain point hopefully
you've
staffed up a successor who is able to do
that for you so you can focus on the
other
kind of higher level things in terms of
where we're taking the team what kind of
projects are we taking on um but for me
it is important that i do write code
from time to time especially as projects
are kicking off
but certainly i think it depends on
where you're at in terms of whether that
should be a daily thing or you should be
actually moving projects forward
yourself
but i think having that skill set is
important to make sure your team's
functioning properly and you're hiring
the right people
yeah absolutely and i love this emphasis
on you know you've mentioned where you
you know if you're starting a project
you're much more involved with code and
ewa you mentioned a lot about like the
stage of the organization um so i kind
of want to pivot a little bit and i'll
throw it to jairus first but i want to
talk about something that um at least on
social media i think it's a lot of play
and that is about hiring
someone with the potential to learn and
grow so we see a lot of advice from
things like i don't meet 100 of the
requirements or i only need 60 and so
you'll see mixed advice from things like
oh as long as you meet 50 you should
apply or you know it doesn't even matter
just apply for it like just go for it
and then you'll see people were like no
you've got to be able to do 80 or 90
so when we're thinking about hiring
someone uh with the potential to learn
and grow how do you assess this in a
candidate
yeah that's a great that's a great
question i think almost everybody is in
this boat where they're not matching all
of the you know criteria that have been
laid out so you know if the company does
indeed you know box number seven does
indeed need that like you have to
convince them that this is something i
can pick up over time
i think one of the best indicators is
just a track record of having done this
in the past so when you're positioning
yourself for the role if you can look at
prior experience and say you know i did
this role and i didn't have xyz but
these are things that i picked up in the
context of it i think that's a really
strong you know you're showing that i've
done this before and i'm looking to do
it again um so that's the best way i've
seen a position because you do have a
lot of candidates who say yeah i'll pick
it up but only a subset of them are like
here's sort of my track record of having
done this in the past in prior roles or
in school or or what have you um yeah i
think actually school is a good example
as well because you have folks who need
to learn a programming language to do a
specific you know project and so they
can they can bring that to light as well
but i think showing that track record is
really effective because it goes beyond
saying you know trust me i'll do it but
like trust me i'll do it because i've
done it before
i would add to like if the candidate
expressed any interest in continuing
education programs at the company
right
so boeing offers a lot of continuing
education programs and so if you're like
um
really interested in learning and
expanding one area say like oh i'm
really interested in geospatial data
science right because there's not a lot
of opportunities for that maybe when you
went to school or whatnot and maybe that
was one of the small things on the
resume and you're like hey do you offer
any internal programs towards this or
somewhere where i could learn and expand
that particular skill i always look for
those kind of opportunities in an
interview too
i'd love to hear from other panelists um
i think my challenge is
doing this for more junior candidates
where
often there isn't that experience so you
kind of have to go off of how they
answer things um if anybody's found a
magic bullet there i'd love to hear from
it but i think that can be the most
challenging spot for me is when
somebody's junior you don't necessarily
have the expectation that they would
have had that experience because you're
hiring a junior role to me those are the
biggest blind spots other than kind of
how they approach the project how they
answer questions
you have kind of the least amount to go
off of to know okay i know this person's
gonna need a lot of support when they
start but how do i get more reassurance
that six months from their starting
point or nine months from their starting
point they're going to be one of those
people who's just kind of
self-sufficient so kind of an ass comes
in maybe it's more vague they will
develop that kind of more um harder to
find skill skill set of managing and
kind of
doing things from start to finish on
their own um i think that can be a
little more challenging for the junior
folks
oh let's go ahead jairus please i said a
real quick thing i saw someone do during
an interview that stood out which is
when you talk about concepts um or
techniques that the person is not
familiar with
people with that sort of growth mindset
will make a note and engage with you
more and say i want to learn more about
this later
some other folks you know they get
really embarrassed i don't know that and
they try to steer the conversation away
and i thought it was impressive when
someone both admits to me i hadn't heard
of that and i will go look it up later
and then sometimes you get the follow-up
email hey i read about this like so that
that really stood out to me as a
positive behavior that i think indicated
the potential for growth in the future
and the interest as well i'll throw it
to you away sure thanks um a couple
things
i think everyone who applies to be a
data scientist at least has
one thing they're more comfortable with
you know so uh whether it's against
statistics or programming in one
language versus another
you know i asked them about that and how
they
you know came about to
pick up those skills
uh it's also you can see also on their
resumes and in their conversations too
you know like hey i stumbled upon this
uh because you know i was a graduate
student in this field and i started
doing data analysis and i realized this
is what i want to do not uh you know x
engineering i don't want to pick on a
particular engineering but you know
um
you know
you know somebody in the x engineering
field does a lot of data analysis and
realize their their passion is in data
and so so tell me what's specifically
about it you know do you like the
programming part
everyone has a thing you know that
they're better they're pretty good at
better than the other uh
better than other aspects of data
science and or they're you know much
more junior
uh i ask about you know uh their
interests outside of data science you
know what's what's the thing that you
you love doing is it you know
ballet dance or cooking you know there's
always disciplines that transfer really
well because in my mind it's about
process and practice i don't i don't see
data sciences any different it's process
and practice
yeah i i will just add kind of quickly
from my um
my experience as being an adjunct
professor and
it is interesting moving from like this
graduate frame of mind to the fact that
you know certain universities are now
offering undergraduate degrees in data
analytics and the breath and experience
is a lot
smaller it's a lot smaller of a window
right and
and teaching the senior capstone class
is really giving me insight on how
students actually think about these and
then thinking about how does that
translate when they go and try to
interview for a job because
you know obviously like most of them
probably just went through the general
education requirements and then those
last
two or three semesters of school they
were really cramming in like all these
kind of analytics classes they don't
know how to describe a logistic
regression to you
you know
they're like they're just you know
really starting at that very fundamental
phrase and um
i will say like i enjoy also mentoring
the students because in in the capstone
class we spend some time talking about
how do you do interviewing strategy
especially like on your resume you were
you know a
uh like you worked at the deli at
safeway or something
right and so i talk about really expand
on that experience working at the deli
counter you know talk about like you
were employee of the month why were you
employee of the month right really
accentuate those those skills and talk
about your areas and passion of why
you picked this major to begin with and
then how can you apply those to this job
if you're given you know the opportunity
to do that and that's that's usually
just general advice they give the
students because
yeah it has been
enlightening seeing it from both ends
so
yeah absolutely and i think something
that everyone's touched on is this idea
of being able to articulate what skills
you have and how they translate to data
science so not all of your skills have
to be in data science but they do still
relate to your ability to do data
science
and related to that we have a question
about thinking about candidates um and
how if at all you weigh their
non-technical contributions to the
broader data science community whether
that's through
social media blogging youtube tutorials
anything that a candidate does that's
maybe
kind of in this amorphous they're not
doing it for work they're doing it
because they're really curious and
passionate does that come into play for
you when analyzed or kind of deciding on
a candidate and if so how
not for me
i mean it's to me their social media
interactions are you know things they
do on their own time which is great
but i don't think it has any bearings on
the actual application itself
it's you know do i think they can do the
job or not
i'd say i have a slightly different um
perspective
i'd say
at the end of the day my focus is
definitely can they do the job or not um
so it's not a requirement by any means i
feel like i've hired great folks who
don't have some sort of
blog or data science side hustle um but
it is a plus when i see that uh because
to me i think what i do care about is
that you are
depending on the level if you're a more
senior candidate that you are going to
be staying on top of like what is new
new packages new trends new programs new
methods right like if you're if i'm
hiring you for doing nlp analysis like
that space is changing so constantly it
would be impossible to think that one
um you know person could keep up with
that and all the different things right
so if that's what you're gonna be a
specialist in i think it's a great like
plus to show your hunger for that um but
i think i've definitely seen folks who
demonstrate that hunger and that kind of
up to speed with current state who maybe
don't have a blog or don't run a chapter
of um you know pi ladies or
our ladies or something um so i think
it's a big plus but i think you can
demonstrate it in other ways
um so that's how i view it
yeah and i'll just say i'd like you know
what we were not necessarily allowed to
participate in the instant things and
say i always
just want to add like
other hiring people sometimes that
should weigh in as part of the
consideration as well but with that
being said um especially like if you're
working in a research and technology
branch i would expect you to participate
in professional
associations um right and especially
like as as part of like the technical
fellowship some of it is like your
external
connections and how people are looking
at you technically but that that is like
at a level of technical excellence right
um
versus like i just like to write and
vlog
so i i would say like during our
interview i i can't really give you an
answer to how that weighs at boeing i
mean to say that sometimes just consider
that maybe those people are not actually
allowed to participate in those channels
as well
yeah to add to this this is a really
tricky one for me because
as much as i think it's fair to say yeah
the person's showing passion they're
showing the ability to maybe build
communities or to engage you know in a
broader sense in data science i don't
want to create a world in which
future data scientists feel like they
need to have a blog or they need to have
an active social media because some
people have no interest in doing that
and i think they should be able to get
data science positions without having to
do it so um i haven't had a lot of
candidates across my desk that do have
hey check out like my data science
twitter um
personally i enjoy them but i i would
just hate to pick someone over someone
else because you know someone is sort of
more naturally inclined to do that sort
of work than someone else and then of
course it depends on the quality of the
work um i think something as simple as
like i have a friend who works for a
large tech company in advertising and
every week explains an advertising term
to all of his followers many of whom
don't work in advertising and i thought
that was a really cool simple way of
teaching folks more about sort of the
ecosystem that he works with he's in
sales so it probably helps him generate
more but just a really small elegant way
to show like i have knowledge and i want
to share with the community and it
doesn't seem like too much of a heavy
lift on i don't think he's applying but
if he was i i feel like that's something
he could bring up and maybe that's a
lighter weight way of of demonstrating
that you have the ability to keep
communicating and participate
yeah really grab this oh sorry go ahead
no no go ahead
oh i'm really glad this this topic is uh
being discussed i agree with katie in
that um you know it's important for
people to stay up to date uh you know i
love twitter because you know i'm an
avid read follower of folks on you know
stats twitter our twitter machine
learning twitter whatever
uh you know so that helps me stay up to
date and find resources there for sure
uh
so this is more of a
cautionary
point in that i also see a lot of
data science
enthusiasts on twitter
who i don't know if this is true or not
i worry that they're learning data
science
or stats too much from twitter there's
only so many things you can there's only
so much you can learn from was it 280
characters i can't remember you know
and
you really have you know this this is a
slow skill that you have to acquire with
hard work not not a fast skill that you
can just pick up with tweets you know
twitter is great for finding links in
you know to longer blogs or resources
but
you know i would not substitute
hey i
i followed this
20
tweet thread and now i know
you know x
skill right um that's just not gonna
happen
yeah i think these are all fantastic um
this is there's a lot of really great
advice in here and i think um
social media is very rewarding but it's
also like that quick kind of reward and
i love this idea of thinking about you
know using social media as a starting
place there is an inspiration but to
make sure you're you're kind of doing
don't let the underlying work of
learning to be a data scientist and
continue growing your data science skill
set suffer for your social media this is
very hard for me to say as someone who
lives on social media but yes do the
work social media is like the candy
later um so i do there's one question
we're gonna kind of drastically shift
gears a little bit because i really
really really want to make sure that we
get a chance to answer this and katie i
would love to start with you
um i would love to know how you think
about and define the differences between
a data analyst and a data scientist
yeah so i'm sure this looks different a
lot of places but um
one kind of division of skills that's
resonated for me so from a technical
perspective if i think of where like our
analysts versus data scientists are
spending their time i think a lot of
analysts are um
spending and tend to be a little bit
stronger on the sequel
typically just to be honest in the
industry bi tools so tableau looker
power bi
um and then my ideal analyst would also
be able to dabble in python or r um so
they'd be able to pick up our python for
some deeper analyses when they need to
um i've come to realize when i got out
of consulting though that a lot of times
they're super strong in sql they do a
lot of that in sql but we found
opportunities for doing something in r
or python instead when that's the better
tool for the job and i'd say from a
job perspective analysts tend to be
just have a greater variety of projects
going on that tend to be more focused
around business problems and kind of
maybe more qualitative post-hoc analyses
versus forward-looking models to
contrast with the data scientist r and
python like strong expertise and one of
those is a must versus kind of a nice to
have or i will teach it as we go
the background statistics is also
crucial i think
some kind of foundations are crucial for
an analyst but i wouldn't necessarily
expect an analyst to be extremely deep
just in the way that i would expect a
data science scientist to maybe be apt
for sitting in on a bunch of business
meetings across a variety of areas and
answering a variety of one-off questions
the data scientist time should be more
focused on protected on specific
projects um and so it's to me from a
skill set perspective that steps
statistics training our python
high level of competency that kind of
set things apart
and a little slightly less kind of
forward-facing with multiple different
kind of stakeholders from a business
perspective
so i will say my first job was a data
analyst because there was no title data
scientist
[Laughter]
and i did the same exact thing
with all honesty but with that being
said um at the boeing company it would
probably come up as a programmer analyst
job kind of what katie was describing
and so i think it's really important
to
not necessarily pay attention to the
title but really read what the job
description is is saying and ask
questions when you get an interview
about the the job itself because yeah it
just there's so much variety and
like you could be a research analyst at
amazon or something for example right
so
yeah if i can chime in here i like i
don't know who's asking the question
they might be a job seeker but um
you know i can give my definitions but
unfortunately when a lot of people in
the industry don't adhere to you know a
strict definition of one or the other i
think the most important thing to do
when looking for jobs is
what as ronda said what does the job
entail and not just what's written but
ask follow-ups because sometimes they
say you're going to be doing seven
things but it's really two of those
seven things that you're going to be
doing um and so try to narrow in on that
sort of as gracely gracefully as
possible but the the thing i've seen
happen in the market because i mentor
students who are going on to get their
first jobs is that
you know data scientists a lot of people
put that above data analysts and
certainly in pay that that happens a lot
but you have a lot of companies now um
treating you know a data analyst role as
and calling a data scientist to generate
more sort of interest in it and so again
focus on what what is it that you're
asked to be doing you know to do what
are the skills that are needed um but
you know if you have a linkedin alert up
now like put both on it i think that's
prudent
yeah i agree it depends entirely on the
on the company um
my experiences
i'll call it analysts
most a lot of companies i see have
analyst positions as part of a function
so
an analyst within the marketing team or
analysts within the operations team
where they'll be responsible for you
know using data to help improve the
operations or just you know
work within that function
and oftentimes they will have you know
sql skills or maybe some other skills
like uh r or python but generally
they typically work with you know
excel which is a great i love excel i
use it all the time so
that's what i see in terms of analysts
and then separately i see
i'll call it bi developers and data
scientists you know there's a lot of
overlapping skills there writing a lot
of sql of course
and then automating the uh the the data
flow
uh the distinction being the bi
developers are primarily about building
and publishing reports reports in
whatever fashion whether it's you know
files or dashboards or what have you
whereas data scientists tend to also
have in addition to that
uh
uh you know the statistical modeling and
insight responsibilities
so those are the three main areas that
i've that i see
this is great um i was kind of hoping
that all four of you would land on a
very clear concise definition that you
all agreed on and we could
solve this problem for the rest of the
industry but it's okay it's okay so i
hope that everybody at home was like i
think this is all really valuable
information i think you know this advice
too if you're if you've got that that
job notification to put both titles in
because
it will vary by industry and it's going
to vary by company so um with that i
would love to kind of think a little bit
about um how you go about shortlisting a
candidate's resume or cv so
in other words what makes someone stand
out to go from that initial
you know we've got 500 resumes what what
do you use to help make that cut or make
that decision for who you're gonna kind
of at least do that initial phone call
with
do we have a review team
yeah i think that's a really important
thing i think it's different everywhere
right so some places the hiring manager
may have to filter all of the resumes as
they come in whereas in other places i
think there is
kind of an hr department or review team
that makes those decisions so i'd love
to hear what your organization uses and
then once you get
the resumes kind of how do you then
start winnowing things down
so i will say like we generally will
start with a list of skills that we're
interested in depending on the position
and then we look to see if those are
somewhat contained
in their resume um
and it really depends on the type of job
like i feel like internships are
probably a lot more flexible
um
right where
um
you know we we have like you can go out
to our internship website externally
right now and you can see the different
buckets that you can apply for for an
internship and so
you know um
once you've applied for that bucket that
bucket will go to a review team and
we'll be looking for some specific uh
different list of skills and those could
be a wide variety of skills because we
have a whole bunch of different managers
right and so i would say there's there's
differently
depending on the type of position and
the type of interview style going on
there's there's kind of a different
process behind each one of those so that
one kind of makes it hard for
to answer
hope that helps
we i'm lucky to have a talent
acquisition function that helps me first
filter on the technical skills you know
i tell them okay
sql and r or python or one you know or
some other programming experience some
preferably quantitative background but
it doesn't have to be it could be you
know liberal arts degree i'm a liberal
arts major
uh and then once i see their resume you
know it's it's uh i don't wanna see a
four page resume with a thousand
programming skills you know less is more
i'm looking for death you know have you
done a few things really well
as opposed to many things
over time
because i'm trying to build a team where
you know we have a team of experts with
different expertise
and so having someone who's really good
at one thing is really valuable so that
will complement someone who's really
good at something else
that's how i prefer to hire but
obviously that's just my personal
preference
i'd say one thing i'd add that i saw on
a few resumes i thought was super cool
were
i know from an applicant perspective it
can be hard to
to list the programming languages you're
familiar with out feeling a little
fraudulent like for me i'm definitely
stronger in r but i know some python but
if i just put python as a language on my
resume it could feel misleading i'm not
like an expert python programmer and
more like basic intermediate
so rather than spelling out all those
with the levels i saw i've seen like on
a sidebar like a nice graph that's
almost like a bar chart of competency
and so you'd have your top like that's
the full bar and then everything else
would be
just arbitrary percentages for
competency it might even be like a
markdown template actually i think for
the the resume that it was generated on
um so check that out i thought that was
just a nice way to showcase hey i'm
confident in all these languages to
varying degrees without having like a
super long detailed section um and it's
a nice little graph so that was cool
do you have to specify the scale
this was not this is just a visual so i
guess it depends on how
how tight you want to be that's how you
trick people i'm a d in my our ability
and then everything else is lower
yeah everything else but if you don't
label it they don't know
yeah i would say like it definitely
depends on a personal perception
with that being said i'd like to point
out like resume formatting right um some
set you know some systems will not take
bar charts into the resume format right
and a lot of times they will get printed
out on gray scale so don't make it all
nice and colorful make make sure like if
you do use color that it's going to look
nice and black and white that's that's
just some of my pointers i give to
students because you see some of them
get really creative and like yes that's
that's wonderful i applaud your
creativity just make sure it looks good
in black and white
yeah the resume is so important just
reminder that we have
typically three to five hundred resumes
to get through so
if you submit a novel it's gonna just
go right past it
yeah that's some other things i say make
sure like you build stuff that somebody
can quickly glance at it in 30 seconds
for the first review right
and you've got their attention then
they'll go back and and look at it a
little bit more detail if they see
something like that really pops out so i
always say like fold those important
things you know and make it about you
because i've i've had like students will
put an order on their resume for example
the last class i noticed did a lot of
this like they'll put the company name
first and not the position name i'm like
no talk about you what did you do you
know the company is relative right i
mean great this was at microsoft but
it's far more important for me to see
what you did at microsoft so i mean just
me personally like i i like that order
of like i can see what you did and then
i'll look and see where you did it at
that's just my own personal preference
but it's like because i want to know
about you i don't want to know about
microsoft for example i'm using that as
an example maybe asian
it doesn't have to be a data science
job that you've had you know if you had
some side hustle in college i think
that's really valuable it shows
initiative for example
yeah we've got tons tons of great advice
and i feel like we
talked to chris i feel like we could do
a whole panel on resumes and how to
build your data science resume
we could definitely keep this
conversation going for another couple of
hours but we are coming up on the top of
the hour and i have been given the
responsibility to make sure that we
finish on time
so with that being said i do want to
give each of our panelists a minute or
two to summarize their best advice for a
data science job seeker or data science
manager um and if applicable to tell us
about any openings they may have on
their team and so to avoid the oh gosh
who goes next we'll go jairus katie ewy
and we'll close out with rhonda
yeah sorry jesse that can you repeat
that the first question it was what is
the best advice yeah so you've got about
a minute to tell
our amazing community and audience what
is your advice for data science job
seeker or data science manager
okay um yeah the the best thing i guess
i i would want to see from job seekers
that a lot of folks
don't i see not doing is putting in a
little effort to understand the business
that they're applying to how it works
and what their products are and it's
amazing what 15 minutes either
downloading it if it's free or looking
at recent news or understanding how the
business is set up can do to set you
apart from other folks because a lot of
folks do come in sort of expecting tell
me the metrics you care about then i'll
tell you about fancy stuff you can do
with it but if i am looking to grow you
within the role and have you sort of act
more autonomously over time i'd love to
see your ability to bring that to the
table instead of me having to sort of
feed you everything so there is always
you know 10 20 of candidates who do that
and i think they get the
disproportionate number of job offers
out there because of their ability to do
so and again i don't think it's a ton of
effort so i think that's something that
can set you apart and again it's it's a
minority of folks who i think do this
and do this well
um we're filling a job like today i'm
sorry everyone but um i know you
mentioned like we can do a plug yeah
we're sending enough for today but if
folks see positions at sirius xm pandora
stitcher or one big happy family yeah
feel free to reach out let me know and i
can give you some advice on what you
should apply to and happy to help you
out as i can
well i actually really agree with that
advice
always come with a list of questions but
i'll try to make this additive
so before i forget we do have an opening
for a senior data scientist so head out
to beam.dental and check out our career
site we'd love to hear from you
i'd say probably
less so i guess relevant at the company
i'm currently at where kind of a mid mid
growth stage startup but for sure
hearing it and some of ronda's answers
etc bigger companies i think it's tough
when you don't know anybody who works at
the company just making sure somebody
sees your resume
so i'd say the additive advice i would
have maybe is like um i mean i am not
above if i'm job searching like
stalking the recruiting team at that
company and messaging them on linkedin
right like just making sure some human
sees your resume i think can be super
important if you don't know anybody
there um because it would be a shame if
it just got tossed out for some silly
reason um so i try to be super hands-on
with all the resumes we see so i don't
have that great phd student slip through
the cracks but i think that can happen
sometimes
just because of the sheer volume of
resumes that that these team gets teams
get and how many openings they have so
try to find a physical human to message
if you can
um
quick plug we have two openings one for
either principal or leads slash senior
data scientist position and it's also
one opening for
senior bi developer amwal as a
telemedicine company so we have lots of
data
in terms of my advice
i think it's important to understand the
distinction between having the technical
skills to do the job of a data scientist
but then you also need to make sure and
this has been mentioned before that you
have the statistics knowledge as well
you can
perform the tasks required write sql
write r
but if you really don't understand what
it is the models represent
that can limit your growth
so that's my advice
all right um so
i always have kinds of advice but uh if
you're female you can do it you can
apply for data science jobs
and
um my my second is um always pick
something that you're passionate about
um you'll be far more interested in it
don't just pick a job just because it's
a data science job um pick something
that you're you're truly enthusiastic
about
um and as far as boeing hiring uh we are
always hiring we are a global company
with
wide vast
diverse
positions open
um and like you could work anywhere from
like spain australia singapore
to the us any
about anywhere in the us you could
imagine um not not everywhere but
good diverse positions so i'd really
encourage you to look at boeing careers
i forget the exact website but i always
pass it around or you can put it in
google and you'll you'll find it pop up
and
i would just say if you are looking for
a job there make sure you use a vast
variety of different terms because
for us it's you know i'm i am a data
scientist at boeing that is technically
my skill code but we also have applied
statisticians applied mathematicians we
have advanced technologists all of those
are similar types of jobs we even have
uh data science engineering skill code
we you know people who focus on ai
machine learning autonomy systems we
have library services we have health
services we have our own fire department
um so there's just a wide variety of job
opportunities for you at the boeing
company that's my incredible awesome
that is amazing so this is such
incredible advice from all of you like
thank you so much for sharing your time
and your expertise so as we close out
our session i of course want to thank
you personally i am going to thank you
on behalf of our studio and especially
on behalf of our community everyone who
is watching live right now and everyone
who is going to tune in over the coming
weeks and months you have been
phenomenal guests uh and i know i've
learned a tremendous amount and i i know
that everyone watching has also learned
an incredible amount so with that our
panel conversation has come to an end
and i want to wish you all a phenomenal
day and i hope we can talk again soon
thank you thank you